what do you what do you what do you have
there Rob found a suspicious package
microphone yeah yeah I just found a
suspicious ain't happy in our office oh
you did yes and what does it say on it
to Jim and Sam morning show okay part of
me thinks that you just did that just
now it was not me well there's no
postage on it no postage on it somebody
did you really not do that
I didn't dude somebody just put it in
the office yep
I mean this is that's a very stupid
thing to do who do you think I mean I
don't even want to say names cuz you
can't like should we open it no you
can't make like a joke of fake mail
bombs that's not my handwriting
no why would anybody do that I that's a
stupid thing to I mean how would they
ever get it in the building
they just didn't just now in their
office I know who did it
somebody who doesn't understand that if
we actually talk about this yes they
keep getting a lot of trouble right
that's a huge HR issue parable you work
for a company you just do that and be
like oh isn't this funny
yeah look people are actually getting
mail bombs yeah right yes right but that
no one says that that's a bomb but we're
talking about it on the air and then
somebody just drops it in the office
well maybe somebody want to drop off
some swag so you want to see what's in
there I'll open it should we open it
well outside don't open them in stock I
bought why would you Travis I mean first
of all it's so light do you think this
has to be one of the all-time stupid
ideas that somebody had okay I can't
even this is not even good it's honestly
this is probably I never I didn't think
that he would get worse than his
behavior at the Christmas party oh my
god
that has gotta be how you could get as
old as Dennis's and still have judgment
that's that poor I'm just trying to have
fun exactly how do you explain that away
a little radio humor yeah oh my god we
turn what happens can we turn Dennis
into HR anyway I'm not gonna do that it
would be such a there's no way
if we did he'd be in so much trouble I
mean for which thing he made a thing of
oats look like a bomb like he put a
thing on it they've got a string coming
yeah what's he doing what's worse making
a fake bomb right or asking an employee
to sit on the the Xerox machine and
Xerox her we've talked about it on the
air it's not like you know I mean I
think with the timeliness of this
insensitive this is way worse I think
yeah I think this is even worse somehow
it's funny is it no like it's funny that
you go like how could
why would somebody think that that that
would be a good idea just the time to
like the time to actually make this put
it in yeah and it like and I'd be like
Dennis doesn't have a lot going it's
yeah I believe that
but don't you like there was no thought
of no how would I explain this to
somebody yep literally anybody also you
know what I did to the guys I feel like
any person the dentist would explain
this prank to they go you did what why
would you do that don't you know like
it's still an unsolved thing it's it's
happening it if they sent one to De
Niro's house what are you doing Dennis I
don't think he has the best judgment no
a sign of them across the country
yeah like why would you do that it's an
FBI case why would you walk around a
corporate environment saying where'd you
get your hair cut that's not know it's
not smart either
no now Dennis really does he misses the
old days doesn't he he misses the old
days of Aragon's
okay here comes this is what he wants by
the way attention he why don't might
have a Dennis on I told him to go in
with it and he just know would be
funnier if you did it it's like no he
misses the old days he's old school
I get it he comes from a different time
I get it Dennis you missed the old days
I had I get it I guess I get cold and
sooner or later right right I don't mind
I get it no I got hurt no they did not
okay but it's insensitive can you say
and this show isn't insensible
now Dennis we try to we try to be the
show for everyone you're not we do we
try to be everyone's friendly morning
show but can you see in the culture in
the world that we live in that this
could easily go south in a hurry
it's just our show come on apparently
you do listen also I told Jim did you
make that just now yeah I was just
goofing around it's really well done
finishing my oatmeal and I said you guys
it's meal that's it yeah no I mean trust
me we take it in good humor okay but
that's you got it was a big gamble we're
probably the only show that would take
that in good humor right right that's
why I did it but you know you know that
we love you I just do it to the show and
we love pranks of course you do we did
we love we're pranksters at the end of
the day yeah you got my back I would
have you back a hundred percent I would
say no no no this was before on the air
of course we would have your back but
you know you could see in a broader
sense where this story would not go over
with most people hmm hindsight being
Vicky just having fun no I know yeah we
don't you think somebody for a Halloween
costume is probably gonna go as a bomb I
would say that right now especially in a
corporate environment megyn kelly has
made dressing up for Halloween a very
sensitive issue but blackface is now I'm
not doing blackface you're sending fake
mail bombs to your coworkers you know
yesterday a buddy of mine sent me do you
remember when Sammy um Billy Crystal
used to Sammy Davis jr. yes I do
there's some blackface was he I thought
you just did the voice I didn't know he
did the full thing there's a video going
around of Jimmy Kimmel playing which
basketball player was he playing Karl
Malone and Jimmy was wearing blackface I
mean ever you know I mean he did it all
the time right
recurring character on the man show
right thousand man show I think so yeah
and it was hilarious if it wasn't the
man show is very early in the late night
show but I think so yeah
times are changing quickly Dennis yeah I
know and we are starting to get to the
point where it's frowned upon to send a
fake mail bombed your coworkers I
wouldn't be surprised if Dennis dressed
up in blackface for hello no we're not
shocked me either and you go it's a joke
I'm I'm not even here's what he would
say I'm my costume is Billy Crystal hmm
as Sammy Davis so it's not even really
I'm portraying an african-american
individual I'm portraying a white guy in
blackface so that's okay right here's
the thing Dennis and I've you know I've
found this to be true as I watch all
these stories happening these people
don't care what the explanation is you
know we have these conversations where
it's like clearly we can get to the
bottom level we know what the intention
was we know nobody got that's not where
we live in a gotcha culture Dennis and
some people you know I didn't get you
cuz we got you know what we got for you
what your back thank you yeah right it's
just it's it's a risk especially when
you you know for me I think adding the
fake fuse to the oats jar is probably
where it gets a little like a little
much a little much yeah that's uh it was
sort of like do you ever see the Bugs
Bunny cartoons when they it's you know
just have something that looks like a
giant firecracker right right that's
exactly right yeah that's all yeah I
don't know if Danny realizes we're
living in a post 9/11 world he's still
rocking in the 90s goals he is all
school and I enjoy that about you I like
that you still like humor first right go
do something for the show yes I
appreciate you doing right yeah I was
got my ear pierced for the show I forgot
about that yeah I did stuff sent a fake
mail send it wow wow you know you should
be in a morning funk got my back though
right of course I have your back are you
kidding me I'm really hoping that they
give you guys a new contract yeah me too
yeah I think so a big one like a thick
contract no you know what a cushy that's
what I'm hoping for - let's go to Nick
in Detroit what's up Nick I was in
tennis first off I don't think no
contract negotiations will go so well
knowing that people are sending you guys
so bomb
you mean you mean you think it could
disrupt negotiations if they found out
that our co-workers were sending us mail
bombs you think that the Nero family
would like that if they were like oh
we're so scared you know grandpa got a
mail bomb and then Denis is like oh no
no no of course right of course that
question are you respecting the de
Janeiro's more than just about anybody
everybody's entitled to their opinion
what do you believe it you know agree
with it or not do you think it's a
conspiracy Denis something's something's
up shoes have you think something's a
little fishy I think so then it has a
lot of that red blood going in him if
you catch my drift it's not it's not
that's not stupid I'm gonna tell you
this right I'm gonna tell you this yeah
you know who you'd get along with very
well Dennis no handsome Rob's dad oh
yeah
why is that mom why does it a lot of
similar opinions well I don't want to
see anybody get hurt no I don't think
you do it's not that's why you said
there's a lobster no right dad doesn't
want to see anybody get hurt no of
course not but we're on one side of the
fence right mm-hmm
Dennis onna make America a great hat no
his head's too small no do you own one
no they don't make him in the kids sizes
yeah Roland just called he he's ordering
a cake for Dennis's last day I don't
know
Roland might have to get like a one of
those files baked into the cake because
we may need to send it to Dennis in jail
I don't know I was I'd sent him my wood
door was a prank for the radio show and
you know yeah now I'm not gonna order
that last pint of ice cream no maybe
I'll maybe I'll donate it to the
cellblock it was really just opal I was
delivering breakfast to you guys there's
nothing in there
string and there's a fuse no it's a
handle Troy it's a handle so that we can
stock gunpowder of course Troy of course
not folks it's oats that way we can get
our fiber and if we don't finish it all
we can carry it by the not fuse handle
because I know to bring it home Jim
likes oats and they don't you know he
likes oatmeal there's no sugar in here
it's weird the Dennis sent the mail bomb
on the day that Jim wasn't here
makes me feel been suspicious yeah in
there what's going on Nick I just want
to ask you boys at Reuters awesome
specifically do you think this could be
some sort of false flag kind of rally up
support for Democrats and condemned
Republicans I have no idea man
you know I'm not wrong I'm not even go
down that road anymore Troy's not
interested he likes Alex Jones when he
screams at [ __ ] but other than that
other than that I'm not getting involved
with any of it no you got enough going
on yeah people take that [ __ ] people get
angry you're not allowed to have an
opinion about it you're not allowed to
say yeah it's a little weird no no no it
was like you're on that side and you're
like I don't know it just doesn't make
sense to me can somebody explain this to
me
Troy I'm out before I watch the girls at
the club bounce into the music and
that's it I just want to make I want to
make dope beats right want to hang out
with Jim and Sam that's it that's it
that's it let's go to Shaun in North
Carolina what's up Shawn
hey Sam yeah I can't I can't help but
imagine club soda Keaney would have a
field day with old dennis the menace to
society over here and it's the menace to
society that's right yeah if we really
this could be a way to get club soda
Kenny hired back you know good call
security
yeah club club he would not be happy
with this one no he would not think that
was funny no you would not sure would
because it's a way to get him back in
but here's the thing if we got him back
in I got to clean up my office yeah cuz
we have to pick one or the other now but
you can't use this to get club soda back
in and also you stay like in order to
get club soda back in we have to act
like it's just oatmeal though serious
right just oatmeal right to oatmeal
right
I mean Troy's argument about the fuse is
strong but I could see it being a handle
I've always been a big fan of Troy I
don't know why he'd want to do this to
me well he was scared he's scared I
really do
you do yeah well usually he's a good guy
sometimes he's a little flawed I I do
give you some stuff for the show though
you look you do and at the end of the
day for me
that's the utmost of importance you know
let's go to Tom in Philly what's up Tom
hey guys how's it go good great Joe Sam
I even love you when Jim's not there you
know oh thank you there's a lot of hate
but all right all right so I wonder all
right give me a break
why why are there such good pictures of
these thugs this seems fake not fake in
that it didn't happen but somebody
started this up these are not real how
are there such good vivid photos and how
did the CNN and the news media get them
right away well I'll tell you the truth
thank you buddy it was a head scratcher
when I saw the foot because you never
see photos of these bombs but usually
the bombs explode so I think you know
they would say well we were able to get
photos of them because they didn't
explode but the photos did go out pretty
quickly actually we should probably Troy
would you want to take a photo of the
package that we got delivered I was
questioning if that was a good idea or
not no I don't think so okay all right
we won't we won't I think it's fine as
long as what I said I think it's fine as
long as we just tag Dennis okay did you
use well you got a point I didn't want
the old you got to keep the oats in he
doesn't want to make a mess at the end
of it I think dennis is concerned if we
if we tweet out a photo is that people
are gonna think that we're taking credit
for his work I think that's the concern
yeah you guys do a lot better work than
I do you think that dennis is concerned
that will steal his punch line that this
was his this was his bit not our bit
exactly so you know as long as we just
tag them and say this is from Dennis
Falcone we'll be fine yours used to like
Travis do didn't you I do I like them
all I always talked to him about his
daughter and I were talking about yeah
Mickey Mouse stuff and Disney World
yeah always when you say Mickey Mouse
stuff you don't mean to demean him you
mean actual stuff that is about Mickey
Mouse of course right right right Robby
yes that's right you panic it a little
bit on the inside doesn't have that
filter it's like just do this send bomb
here and then and then it's like when it
comes down to it you explain why this a
bad idea you explain why this is a bad
idea because we're very sensitive to
this and you shouldn't probably do this
and the fuse coming out of the
the thing and they say oh yeah probably
wasn't a good idea
dennis is a shoot first ask questions
that guy here's why I love Dennis he
wears his heart on his sleeve he really
does you know mm-hmm
there's the what you see is what you get
if he likes you you're gonna know if he
doesn't like you you're gonna know and
if he wants to send you a fake mail bomb
you're good
he's probably in Hell right now trying
to get the Christmas channels together
and right you know what I need a little
humor in my life today all day every
time the phone rings every time his
email alerts go off he's gonna be
worried that the wrong person has been
listening to the morning show this
morning
hit me why [ __ ] can I do this why did I
do that I don't think I have to worry
about that
Oh many people take to the morning show
well you normally kidding I do of course
of course a weekend he's gonna think
about it all week I need I need gym
yesterday I wanted him to give me a list
of all his songs that he's missing
what are you give me you know I could I
could download them for him because I
have an account he's giving to him mercy
you see account for that well it's my
own account
sharing music but if Jim already
downloaded them he doesn't have to pay
for him again i but he can't find them
yeah they go back and read download them
if you're paying for a surf ID you have
to pay again to redownload them run like
three or five computer different
computers I didn't know that's allowed
then what's the difference of me sharing
it well what are you talking about now
an Apple account or your DJ account yes
I see I see tennis you know what
happened there
I've Dennis was trying to distract us
all and he was talking about giving Jim
music you realize like oh no Sam's right
I am talking about music I got to move
on from this to I can your losses buddy
Dennis is going from one felony to the
next here's the issue with Dennis
there's two piles of [ __ ] on the floor
and he walked in both of them just both
he's he's trying to scrape both shoes on
the stairs right now getting all that
[ __ ] off of them it's okay
could I go and record my last show I
mean III I'll tell you this Dennis I
would never let that happen to you I
would support you I go I need Dennis
here because he'll attack my enemies and
give me free music I need him to stay
he's a hard worker I mean he works ass
off he's a great worker part of the show
of the show and intricate
to grow that's it right yeah integral
yeah
mmm an integral integral that sounds
very Long Island what you say that
integral to help her part of the show
okay one of the most important parts of
this show I would rank you above [ __ ]
love very very important part of the
show does and we would never never not
let you beat you I was right into
integral so long as Travie you got my
back
Dennis I always have your back right he
wants to have those Mickey Mouse
conversations you're a good guy done all
right
wait that's not no that was not a yes or
no that was very good mr. Eckman oh very
good and Dennis just wants to hear the
positive so he's ready to move right on
oh yeah keep it moving but I don't know
Troy didn't say yes or no I like Dennis
he's a good guy but this was a tough one
for you this is a good guy help try out
at times you want help Troy I see you
got him you call them try try definitely
try yeah he said I helped try out at
times it's like you know just words now
oh the O is silent and this definitely
has helped me out I appreciate it
you got it Zack that's what friends do
right that's right
Rob you got his back always that's all
just that's what friends are for good
that's what that's what I've heard
mm-hmm let's go to Garrett in Washington
what's up Garrett what's happenin
how you doing yep good good hey so what
I thought was strange about the packages
they all went to all these different
states and locations and that I wound up
there at the same day like within
minutes of each other well I mean it was
over the course of a couple days no one
didn't one wall one day like four yes
there were multiple for sure it's like
ten bombs over the course of days yeah
right like three yesterday at seven the
day before you know like Oh Obama got
one oh so it's so got one you know like
it's strange to me how the US Postal
Service got everything there on the same
day and the stubble you see pictures of
it like see it is the stamps don't even
look like they got ran through the
[ __ ] post office well are also
everything's scan mail for a CNN one was
hand-delivered by a messenger oh I'm
here to deliver yeah well okay so the
crazy bomber didn't think it all through
did the messenger have a hard drive of
hits attached to his waist don't worry
it's just breakfast saying does it
everything gets scanned I mean to the
post office
oh yeah yeah yeah everything again sent
gets scanned yeah right I mean note you
know you how is it hand-delivered if all
the other ones came from Florida I think
it may have been sent right I don't know
all I know is that it was brought by a
messenger service rob was a messenger
here yeah I mean it did go to that's
what I recall reading a messenger of
death for you think it's like weird for
the post office to deliver things in the
same area on the same day no priority is
two to three is wherever you are what it
enters the post office right I was gonna
get scanned yes so what a trace of
gunpowder or something oh oh you mean
like skin I thought you meant skin like
just kept no skin no he paid enough all
of them had just you know Sam stamps on
them so there's nothing being scanned he
didn't he didn't print out you know a
priority mail slip okay so he didn't go
to a host on but when you go to the post
office and you're mailing a package they
always ask you is there anything
explosive yeah he probably jump say no
yeah very good deal I think
yeah guess he have stuck get the FBI
involved they need Dennis to help give
them some information do you think he
said no when in reality the answer was
yes you know he's gonna be in trouble
for lying
yeah that's right why did the post
office now that means you could have
dropped him off in a mail box though no
didn't have to post off if you had
enough stamps on them yeah yeah yeah of
course
well they say they've got those bins in
the in the post office that you can just
drop anything off that's prepaid right
right real quick yeah of course I have a
friend who works for the post office and
he posted some on his Facebook and so
I'm just gonna take I don't know I'm
just telling you what he said a guy yeah
works at the post office says no one can
mail an envelope thirteen ounces are
heavier without bringing it to the
window an email processing machine will
flag an isolate and envelope with bulk
should it make it from the box to
sorting machine the USPS will not accept
packages without return addresses and I
guarantee if you have the Clintons or
Obama's address on the Postal Inspection
Service will immediately alert an
inspector dispatch post haste haste I
don't know what that means that means
very quickly after a psychology of how
no one in their right mind would skip
out on the anyway so you gotta be honest
this guy he works at the post office and
he sounds like he might be sort of
drifting towards fitting a stereotype
I'm just saying no you're right am I am
i who am i but I don't think that is
correct though we're probably the first
parts not true at all you can mail
something that's 13 ounces without going
to the window you just drop it in the
business it's prepaid you could just
drop it in the bin that's what the bin
is for yeah yeah I mean I I know that
this wasn't a flat package it wasn't you
know a book or no he's actually it was
him it was like yours there's a male
problem his oatmeal is about the size of
a jug of oatmeal down his young except
with a fuse on the end um in a manila
envelope right as Troy said it was a
handle no I said but I said was a fuse
true and he goes yeah handle it was a
him yeah I think it was a hand yeah a
little portable brekkie for the boys um
yeah there's that machine we're gonna
allows you to weigh stuff and you can
got the postage right there and you can
just drop it in the bin there too but
yeah I think you could just go to a
mailbox on your corner if there's R if
you can get a package and know it well
you're not supposed to if that that's
where maybe that's what Troy's friend is
saying you can't drop anything that's 13
ounces or more into just your corner
mailbox but you can put it in the box at
the post office
yeah let's go to New York Mike what's up
say I might think you're the best man I
really enjoy you and I got the best day
of radio I love Troy quad I love Travis
yeah I love Anthony mob but I think the
only way that Dennis Falco and I love I
love Dennis back home but I think the
only way he gets out of this mess he
created and sophomore he's got to suck
himself for four funny guys they
answered that ninety nine thousand
dollar question and if he could do that
you know then you know you guys signed
the declaration saying that you're not
going to go to HR what do you think
about that I mean it's not a bad
suggestion and you know from a corporate
standpoint if a guy can do that what can
you really hold against him exactly you
know just be impressed you don't like
that stuff Dennis up the mullet over
consider it think about it okay he's
gonna Molotov get a rib removed he's gay
well I think actually I had heard he had
that's what he did oh it's already out
that's my that's a rumor that I heard I
don't know if it's true is it true no oh
just flexible uh date like Marilyn
Manson there's thing it was merrily like
after Dennis heard Marilyn Manson did it
there I did it no that's why I heard you
heard incorrect okay all right well you
would know that false news all right
Chris in South Carolina hey guys amen
hey I know you're talking about the
mailbox and everything there is a an
online service called Dick's by mail
that you can mail somebody a dick bomb
and it will explode tiny little confetti
dick all over the place now does it
explode or does is is just one of those
things where you open the envelope and
the confetti falls I think it's one of
the we're just spring loaded it's like a
- oh my god like a snake like a fake jar
of peanuts when you open it up and row
there's all these dicks flying at me now
like the can of worms also sending them
a back it's got gummy dicks and on the
front of it and says eat a bag of dicks
yeah that's good maybe generally sending
in to somebody that you hate right I get
that maybe Dennis to send one of those
to us no no he said hate oh and you
wouldn't do that of course not
oh yeah it's got a spring in it and
everything Wow yeah that seems I wonder
how busy they're gonna be what the dick
bomb company would it be great if all
these things for dick bombs you know we
we finally x-rayed these things and I
was actually just 10 dick bombs that
were sent out yeah what'd you say
there's also a full sales yeah there is
let's go to that's for the fall of
Dennis Falcone let's go to Dave in the
Bronx what's up Dave hey what's up Sam
are you doing good yeah I think the big
conspiracy is that the government
doesn't scream the mail that's why they
post it you know who squeeze the mail we
do when they after that stupid question
the in the window this is explosive in
the click yes or no that's what I said
yeah there's no follow up on it there's
no ok he said no so there's no
so the answer is no would send it gotta
believe yeah the one that I saw Governor
Cuomo yes yesterday talking about that
the one that they send George sorro's
was our Monday and that they detonated
it that they had to add they x-rated
so once the there is no X rayed I think
that's the bigger conspiracy they only
reach the fact that they released all
these things so that we could look for
it it's because they have no idea that
they went through the milk system in the
first place
I see I see yeah thank you buddy um who
knows it's a big mess though we have to
take a break - but you think so yeah you
feeling you feeling it in your guts to
get the bubble guts no I gotta get into
the studio what for at this point yeah
really
you're in a studio yeah that's actually
true I need no one's holding you here
you can walk out yeah like a this is
weak we gotta take a break yeah Dennis
with the pronouns today to take a break
yeah no you're right no we should we
should take a break
are you gonna talk about what you did
this morning on your Dennis the Menace
show on the seventies channel nope
you're probably try to let this one go
maybe by the wayside yep okay we're
available on demand yes you are but
right no of course not in this one
instance this will make the best of I'm
sure Oh Troy why would you say it I just
want you don't want people to forget
never forget October 26 2000 18 forget
the Denny bomb incident
I mean whoever I think you said it ray
Dennis is old school you hit the nail on
the head this is something it's a prank
that any radio station in the country
for decades it would have been like
that's our wacky morning guy it's like
when you know people justify you know
like back in the day I used to beat your
wife I'm surprised that you guys didn't
send someone out in blackface yesterday
why on earth like would we do that on
any level okay good I'm glad you did but
why would we why would you assume that
we would do that you know I bet you one
kid he wanted to know I wouldn't know
you think it was volunteer to do it away
no we've got the white gloves in a way
drawer his desk
you know who's ready for it no way he'd
get outside back maybe this wasn't a
good idea right but in the beginning
he'd be like god this is gonna be funny
this is gonna be good yeah yeah there's
a lot of wonder there's a lot of people
around the office are asking why Danny
has shoe polish in his drawer but he
wears sneakers you know people don't
can't quite put two and two together on
that why would you think that we'd send
somebody out in blackface I'm glad you
didn't but why would you think that we
would I don't know I think maybe at one
time you might have entertained it not
me a little terrible joke I promise
you're getting it no point in my life
and I said yes to a lot of things good
what I've entertained the idea of doing
something like that good but that makes
me proud of you probably wouldn't send
oats the way you said no it's a fuse
well I didn't want to say that is a
handle and as a handle it was a handle I
know I know I know but his handle would
be like a you so you could hold it
historically yes but in this instance no
you know it's just you could still you
kind of like hold it like a satchel you
know what I mean just like drape the
string over your shoulder hold it by the
string carry the oats behind you that
way if you get hungry you can
cook yourself up some oatmeal in a
microwave to make some shirts
commemorative shirts and say remember
that basically I did this as a test to
you guys and you failed how do we fail
you should have just called security oh
oh my god well yeah imagine let me tell
you something
if I was a bad guy wait a second let me
retract this if I was a bad guy yeah
does a mean person like a venomous
person right I would have absolutely
just like on the Aragon like Travis no
Troy I will not let you open that we
better call security
boy would that have been a rough winter
goose would have been cooked yeah yeah
maybe not such a good idea there's
security footage of Dennis going from
his office to our office anyway quick
investigation well we got to the bottom
of that in a hurry video of him cutting
the string to look like a few years
going upstairs to get the rap laughing
laughing to himself the fuse was a
mistake in hindsight yeah like if you
would've just sent the oats then it's
like all right I'm just sending them
breakfast and it's like why would you
put a fuse on the breakfast as a handle
who's a hint that's insane it was it was
a handle it was a it was a it was a ham
- why would you tape the top - it know
what the oats default that makes sense
because if you're carrying it by the
handle right right you can't if it's
knit the top isn't secured on if it
isn't a fixed true how are you gonna
transport it it's kind of like going
through the airport security with like a
cap gun right now and being like what
joke well you know that gun do they saw
the cigarette lighters that look like
the cap guns sure they exist you know
the Switchblade combs right hmm what
those are cool like everybody's so
stressed out it's a joke relax it's a
comb right I come from a different time
this is funny right look at my hair I
need the comb your prop comic right
right that's all that's all yes all you
know it's no big deal hugging your oats
hugging it oats
it's one of those thing you know when
you like you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up and
and you can feel it in your body and
like you just you want to escape
everything you just you want time to
pass so badly because that's the only
cure like
for a few days it's all over but in this
moment like today's gonna be a rough one
doesn't know what's gonna happen right
nothing will happen I'm nice working
with Dennis why would you say nothing's
gonna happen remember he's like we just
take a goddamn break already no no do
this to myself how many times in my life
I've done this to myself
is that right can't go to the Christmas
party DJ every person that you talk to
that Christmas party that looks at you
and smiles today nobody was overly
offended by the whole thing
no last year's was fun where was last
year's at the Manhattan s'en oh okay
yeah did you go Dennis no can't go can't
go well Dennis gets a couple in him and
he's a little unpredictable that's all
no loose cannon
look Hall and Denny don't mix here's the
thing
see but wait Denny did that Dennis
Falcone didn't write the character
character okay now we're getting
somewhere now we're getting somewhere
Dennis is the one guy left in this
industry that still wants to have a
little bit of fun on radio the one guy
left in this building that wants to have
a good time god forbid right Dennis you
see nothing fun the miserable faces that
walk around this building like do you
know what you do for a living what are
you so miserable about it thank god
there's one guy left little prankster
the last professional funster that's
right the one guy left that wants to
have a little bit of fun in the morning
and what does he get he just wants to
send a little prank mail bomb for a
little fun get [ __ ] for it you know you
got my back then of course I do want
that okay get that writing Wow that'll
probably a face-to-face conversation you
know Dennis whoo yeah exactly
no we need it we need the fun here we
need somebody who actually still has a
good time thank God dennis is here thank
God yes I just wanted to pitch in
because Jim wasn't here today and I
appreciate it I need the help
oh you don't come on don't flatter me
you know good enough to do afternoons on
entertainment radio but no I was not
good enough for that
now might have to send him some oats
yeah I mean all these kids walk around I
should be getting paid more this I don't
know why they're making me do this
I want to work for this channel I've
been here for four months and no
appreciation I told you to stop saying
that exact well I had to learn my lesson
the hard way yeah Dennis on the other
hand he's like look what we get to do
for a living we get it we get to touch
the public right not actually and we
don't do that we learned that in the
Christmas tree a hard way yeah but yes
metaphorically mmm and mentally we get
to touch the people sure right you got
it you get to connect connection not at
the Christmas party nope but on the
radio you get to connect like an idea
Dennis yeah you should show up to the
Christmas party this year with a bomb
dressing why would you say that no no
come on try Dennis wouldn't do that
denne denne might but Denny is some
made-up character you know forget it
you're gonna get mad at the guy who
voiced wily coyote mm-hmm
no you know cartoon character like me
myself and Irene Jim Carrey had all
those exactly it's make-believe right
it's for fun it's for fun it's for
mourning funsters let's go to jail okay
you know what hang on a sec Jeff Jeff
brings up a good point [ __ ] love to
get a haircut yesterday I wonder where
he got it will you get your hair cut
okay that's nice to put the two together
the one by itself is like okay but the
two together it's like it's wild right
yeah yeah it's wild and then they go
like okay okay
Dennis we get the Oats thing could you
explain the origin of you going around
the office asking coworker no I didn't
ask co-workers just it in the studio
that's not true I go to you guys when I
walk by the office and in the kitchen
definitely when I see you guys right you
dots right exactly when I do it to
someone I don't know we're not your
co-workers you won't yeah but it you're
my show mates right friends coach don't
say friends co-star co-stars I consider
supporting I consider you a friend
we're a supporting cast to Deborah
Dennis's to the dentist yes to his Ennis
show the den show just goes on always
and it's not the Dennis show it's the
Denny show right the character right of
Denny Travis do you think this is this
is gonna go fine right yeah he's got
nothing worried about we've all got his
back
yes well that's right not Troy Troy he
likes him though I do I do like that but
he hasn't made any declarative statement
about having his back no and look when
push comes to shove I certainly will not
you know walk out in protest of Dennis
no but okay why would you bring that up
a sudden him a Christmas card
I don't think Dennis wants to get any
mail from you it could be retaliation
that's what you do yeah I certainly
don't want mail from him maybe you go
into the HR office and if they're like
Dennis we got to let you go and you go
dan hey HR before you say that cross
this out before you say that before you
make that decision
maybe next time it's not oats no of
course okay no now wouldn't happen well
the meetings not sending oats the
meaning is not gonna happen
because you're being a morning funster
doing a gag on the radio that's all I
can idea Dennis when you send out your
Christmas cards you should put a little
baby powder and some people don't
anthrax do you see that thing is I'm
doing it on the show on this show on the
air for the show for the show
that's answered the show right right
funny now were you when I reacted the
way I reacted to it initially was it a
feeling of dismay like why yeah I said
did you find yourself agreeing with my
sentiment yeah like if I could place
myself on the outside usually when I do
something like that and you kind of
bring it around and he's right so this
is kind of like when when Nicole from
the morning mashup went on the air and
announced that she was pregnant right I
was when we're doing the after sir she
and now she was pregnant
and literally two minutes after she was
off the air you approached her and said
you know Nicole you have to be careful
because a lot of DJ's don't like to
announce you know pregnancies I knew I
worked with a guy who announced his
wife's pregnancy on the air and the baby
was stillborn well yeah because you
don't want to move it that was just 2
minutes after she I understand when I
was she was showing I was just doing to
help her how is that helping you can see
where that would be the last thing she
wanted to hear though in that moment I
tell you I went to church every day and
prayed you know what is it Dave god
forbid
this one's on you imagine if that
actually happened it'd be on him it
would be yeah that would be tough
Fitness do you realize though that your
judgement isn't always the best oh yeah
we all have problems with that at times
yeah yeah of course
you know Dennis really makes them big
blunders though we got his back I got
his back I should say I like Dennis is
cool okay that's not what I asked got
him got himself caught up close to
saying cool now yeah I went from okay to
cool right
so let's go and I said I love lightness
yes you do right that's all that's all
that's all
all right well Dennis I appreciate you
stopping by mm-hmm contributing on a day
where I needed the hope right you know I
can't handle these things on my own
Jim's not here I'm sitting here going
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
rambling about god knows what you know
nice bombs yeah trying to talk to a
[ __ ] brick wall about you know mail
bombs that everybody's already heard
about who gives a [ __ ] about any of this
why would anybody care about my opinion
thank God and you come in and save the
day save the show past it up huh classed
it up with some humor you talking about
the oats thing yeah that was classing it
up yeah okay I wouldn't say it's a note
saying say it's a fake bomb why don't
you bring it up and past it dude
we're past that we're not going back
there we're past it okay it's a notes
thing yeah don't don't see the fuse
thing again either we're past all that I
could have gone to a novelty shop you
know with all these Halloween pop-up
stores and me and bought a fake bomb
okay where that would be totally yep
insensitive and actually you bringing it
up is worse yeah well I want you know
what I wonder how many stores are not
selling fate behind yeah I mean
hold back on that yeah yeah trinkets
don't get them try a little music trivia
for you here how about a song by the Gap
Band do you think that's being played
anymore Travie well it's what song is it
you know what song that is yes I do
could you give me the title
I dropped the bomb on time bomb you drop
the bomb on you you dropped a bomb on me
right yeah so you think that that song
is not being played anymore but hmm it's
appropriate to doesn't deliver oatmeal
yeah that's what we're gonna say Troy do
you hear are you listening yeah or pass
the other stuff the fake bomb don't do
it again man we're past it we're
delivering oatmeal can you say that
please what did Dennis do this morning
past it oh you speak in the head
sometimes men we're past that
the fake bomb thing we're past it okay a
fuse what yeah I know I know it was
there we all ate this we all saw it
he's sweating a little bit buddy this
one a lot we're past it Travis you get
this queued up for 10:30 addressed it
yeah of course okay yeah dude no I'm so
far past Dennis trying to incite terror
okay we're past that don't ya don't even
bring and don't even you know try it
yeah Travis is right I'm glad he phrased
it that way too because he's right we're
past that
dennis has taken that with him
incinerator let me tell you something
dennis is gonna be eating oatmeal all
day now that kernel is gonna be left
nope nope not one oat is gonna be in
there I wouldn't be surprised if he
takes that home with him right so there
is no evidence I would imagine I would
imagine it's too bad there's video
evidence shoot yeah there's cameras
running in studio darn it they always
get you with the cameras don't they
god damn millennium makes it on YouTube
huh this makes it on YouTube should I
put the way to what makes it on YouTube
Dennis make it a fake down right we've
got comport otally past that you don't
think people fans of the show I'd love
to see that we'd love to see this
segment but we're calling this segment
dennis brings a fake no no no we're not
we're past that dennis delivers oats
dennis brings us out that's with a fuse
all right I'll go with oats but we say
delivers oats with a fuse no it's a hand
handle handle we're going with handle
for the for the sake of everybody for
the YouTube
we're gonna stay well I don't we'll
figure that out after okay look I was
checking the pad data to make sure we
were being respectful to Dennis yeah
what's up I'm not thrilled to tell you
the truth oh all right I'm not thrilled
and I'm thrilled Dennis why are they
always trying to play pranks on you
maybe it's because you send them Wow you
know what that was that'll change it
that came around on an old version we're
done with show it's a kind of shouldn't
recycle what was done on an old dennis
is 100% correct I'm changing right now
okay good hackidu can't wait to see this
one I said adds insult to injury right I
mean how does he injured he's the one
that's well sent us oats changed okay
thank you it's not blowing up okay look
Travis that really doesn't help at all I
need you to just say just right Dennis
Falcone brings us outs please
because boats no no I don't want that
word in there that says terrorist bomber
on it and I don't want that there
terrorist bomber Dennis Falcone if you
would a lot of people are tweeting us
that it said self sucker
Dennis Falcone I like Dennis said that's
from an old show right I'm trying to
create a new wacky character for Dennis
here Travis is getting a lot of props on
Twitter today for the Pat data yeah
good for him so just regular old Dennis
Falcone brings us outs
Dennis Danny Danny Danny Danny that's
very important to this whole thing I
like that you're building a defense
Danny Danny brings oats right
parenthesis should I hire the same
lawyer that megan kelly is hard no I
think you need the the woman from making
a murderer
clearly we're sunny notes clearly it was
just sending some oats to the show he's
a friend no fan of the show I'm just
gonna make the bomb again to see how do
we know that little handsome Rob didn't
actually address the envelope how do we
know where's the evidence I've made a
bomb of votes just to prove to you that
the fuse looks more like a handle than a
few we're getting digging out we're
gonna get him out we're gonna get him
out yeah no I'm still in the studio I'm
still I'm still stuck in the studio yeah
I can't move I can't get up
I didn't know I sent them all
I sent up yeah I know I did look like
that yeah I thought it was a handle pad
it has changed I think I'm good we can't
see it though well I I have ax it okay
what is the oh no Travis you I did
exactly what your absolute inning
because you added in a little
editorializing and I told you I'm trying
to tell you guys were past this and you
guys aren't listening to me was it's a
it's a bomber
no no then don't bring that up again Rob
please we're past it right
it says Denny brings explosive oaks
which doesn't you know what just leave
it for now it's enough we'll go to Bill
in LA so compromise Oh Travis you suck
man you changed it to terrorists bomber
I laugh so damn hard I almost hit the
person to the right of me jerk and a
steering wheel oh my god this is
hilarious
Dennis is causing car accidents to hell
oh thank you very much bill not having a
good day Dennis I think he's having a
great day he brought some great humor to
the show gave us something to run with
on a day that Jim's not here and quite
frankly I could use the help
clearly uh you know so I appreciate you
Dennis brought a bomb into this no Rob
sorry
we're totally past that oh we've made it
clear what it was we're totally past it
he didn't do that
Dennis doesn't think this is funny
anymore no he doesn't because he agrees
with me right we're past it aren't we
now I think so you know what though
people on Twitter love this segment they
do somebody just said this segment was
the bomb oh Jesus Christ she's telling
they're telling Jake screen grabbed it
outside business to take care of come on
guys
let's knock that off it should be Denny
the oats man that's it I can do that
breakfast Denny that's all that's all
you guys are mean it's not right what
you're doing just giving some fiber to
the boys right right that's it okay
fodder and fiber that's what you're here
for fodder and fiber that's it well this
wasn't nice the guy that said that this
segment was the bomb yeah he hashtagged
self sucker why would you add that it
man well you can couldn't see it I'm
just letting they just all they're
listening now yeah I know but it lived
on Twitter only and now it's for the
whole audience I'm way past that Olsen
your everything I'm past that too
actually you're right that's just at
this point to bring that up it's hack
it's over right down through that Oates
man [ __ ] on the pad data for you hey
thank you you didn't try this you
editorialized absolutely did you heard
any the Oates but then he makes sense
when you wrote it says Denny the oats
Bomberman does not think this is the
humor is he's right he is gone he's
right about this he's like you guys are
running this into the ground right
please stop there's no reason to milk
this to the last drop he asked you to go
to break literally 25 minutes ago is
that how long ago it was all because I
do really have something to do go right
just walk out on the show I appreciate
that and I'm sure a good guy we have
your back we thank you for the breakfast
which you delivered to us mhm
you know Rob did you kind of know what
was gonna go this way when you brought
the thing in I saw you check in Rob did
the responsible thing he checked with
Travis I swear to God when I saw you
check with Travis I was like tell me
this handsome little [ __ ] is going into
business and doing bits now cuz I was
gonna yell at you to be like how stupid
is that bit oh and then when you were
like it's not my bit I was like what
someone made up uh come today
you know office and just been like it'd
be funny plus you can't get mailroom
deliveries at 8 o'clock in the morning
here right don't have to be an inside
job mm-hmm you know I told him just
bring it down there as a goof that's all
I said
let me ask you something Dennis have you
at a time machine what would you do with
it not do it let's zip back to old 8:10
a.m. I'm gonna pray the train was late
today yeah stuck in the tunnel yeah yeah
you go you go back into that six o'clock
hour huh oh yeah oh yeah no reason you
you switchover you go let me see what's
going on on the Howard replay this
morning huh no no it would have been
better for you hmm
in this instance I'm sure they've done
some stuff work across the line to
exactly we've all done in the name
of humor right you're a humorist
entertainment and entertainment and
infotainment right right you want to
bring a little of that information in as
well you know dennis is bringing what's
that danger tainment
with his bombs I'm into first of all
Travis I wish you hadn't added in the
last part cuz we're way past just want
to make sure you got it I did get it but
we're way past it although danger tame
and Danny is the thing heyday
entertainment Danny does work for me
would you would you classify yourself in
that category danger tainment mm loser
tainment no Dennis don't be hard on
yourself that's not true I'm dangerous
funny okay danger - yeah
danger